very enjoyable to be able to participate
in the culture to that extent in the
target language hi there steve crawford
here
again and today i want to talk to you
about culture this is the
seventh and
last of my
personal goals in language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell on
the bell for notifications
and if you enjoy my podcasts please
leave a review
we do appreciate it all right
so i've been going through these sort of
seven personal goals when it comes to
language learning
uh in sort of a hierarchical order
my first goal is to learn as many words
as i can and that remains a goal
increasing my vocabulary then
i want to have that vocabulary so that i
can start reading it's kind of the
easiest thing to do once i can read then
i can make more sense out of what i
listen to so then i increase my
listening
with the sort of listening i develop
some momentum which gets me to speaking
when i speak i realize the gaps and my
grammar in my usage so then i focus in
on grammar it's sort of in that order i
don't start with grammar for example
then in my last video i talked about
writing which can be a powerful way of
improving
our skills in the language
but it's not something that i've been
doing a lot of recently but i still
recommend that's an important way of
improving in the language and then this
all brings us to the culture
which is an important motivator for me
because i want the reason i learn these
languages is to get closer to the
culture of those languages to learn more
about them for those countries and
people and cultures to come alive for me
which they do when i have an
understanding even an imperfect
understanding of those languages ideally
i want to approach those cultures in the
language that i'm learning
so sometimes
if at an early stage
in learning the language i get too much
explanation
of the culture of festivals of special
names for
relatives or any of this kind of detail
uh in english or a language that i speak
well
i find it difficult to absorb uh
it's not so meaningful to me that's why
i resist it because once i've had enough
exposure to the language
where
i've been in situations or i've watched
movies where people refer to their
mother's
brother in certain ways so these
names for different family members or
even references to
uh you know culture like festivals or
you know in terms of persian uh how they
eat and the no ruse and all of this kind
of thing
is more meaningful when i can access it
in the target language
but of course we are dealing with the
culture from the beginning because when
we're
learning another language we're
imitating that language we're imitating
a portion of the culture because the
language is part of the culture so the
language
is in itself part of the culture that
we're learning
but the fine points of the culture the
sort of how people interact with each
other
uh
this
comes alive better when we have a better
understanding of the language
and uh it might be through watching a
movie or a series on netflix that we
come
closer to a turkish family arabic uh you
know problems in egypt having to do with
the role of women and these subjects
that are very often treated in in movies
or series and if we can access them in
the target language we sympathize more
with with the people
so
and that's very enjoyable it's very
enjoyable to be able to participate in
the culture to that extent in the target
language similarly
when we have enough of the language that
we can be with those people
and communicate in the target language
understand what they're saying
participate in how they react with each
other
uh participate ourselves in the target
language that
in a sense is sort of the
the final achievement that's in a way
the ultimate goal we want to be able to
do that but the reason i make it my
seventh goal is that
i feel a lot of other things have to
fall into place
in order to be able to
enjoy the culture in that way
that's not to say you can't
you know watch movies with subtitles i
mentioned for example that they're
watching uh russian movies like just
toki romance at an early stage in my
learning
relying on the english subtitles was
never nevertheless a great motivator for
me
but watching that same movie and
understanding what they're saying
is
is a much richer experience
so as with many of the sort of hierarchy
of goals
my greater emphasis at a particular
stage might be on reading or listening
or or whatever but there's still
elements of all of these goals at every
stage
it's just a matter of how much emphasis
so at an early stage i may resist a
great emphasis on festivals or
these kinds of things but if i'm now at
a stage say in persian where i can read
like sahara did for me on link she
created a
course on iranian history a course on
iranian food of course on
different minorities iran in iran if i
can
access all of this information in the
target language to me that's that's the
time to do it so i tend to want to save
it
similarly you know reading
novels
um
in translation is not as attractive to
me as waiting until i can read those
novels
in the target language
uh
so i kind of save the cultural
thing the bulk of it until i have enough
of the language
but i don't deny myself some peaks at
the culture at an early stage you know
there's so many more opportunities for
us to access different aspects of the
culture today than was the case before
i've mentioned several times
the jordanian cartoon series
which is very much aimed at at a
jordanian audience with cartoons it's a
bit like the simpsons but with certain
little morals in every episode
uh hayate
and family life it's called
i can access that using link granted
sentence by sentence going through the
words netflix enables us to access
you know series where we kind of find
the same family every series and they're
speaking in that language and we're
trying
as much as we can to understand what
they're saying and so there's just so
many more ways we can access the culture
than was the case before and we can
access that
aspect of the culture that's of interest
to us far too often
uh in textbooks the textbook writer
wants to introduce to you
those aspects of the culture that they
think are interesting or that you should
know
whereas i think we're it's more
satisfying to access those aspects of
the culture that are of interest to us
and that could be anime in the case of
japanese it could be
k-pop in the case of korean and i think
as is the case with all aspects of
language learning where it's meaningful
where you are you are doing things of
interest to you
things that you find enjoyable you're
going to do better and so
this final goal then the seventh goal of
accessing the culture
is best done when we take the initiative
we choose things of interest to us if
we're able to access it in part or
wholly in the target language it makes
the whole exercise more meaningful so
there you have it this is the seventh
and final video on this subject of my
language learning goals my hierarchy of
language learning goals
so it started with accumulating
vocabulary which remains a goal and then
reading
uh reading leads me on to listening
listening leads me onto speaking
speaking makes me aware of my
shortcomings in usage
from there i
want to work on my writing in order to
improve my usage and when i have all the
pieces of the puzzle put together then
i'm better able to access the culture
now i did a couple of videos i've done
some videos on this subject before and
you might want to have a look at them
one was called culture and language
learning and the other one is first
learn the language then the culture so
thank you for listening and that's the
end of this series bye for now